megan v stallion teaches me a lesson
about true equality and female
empowerment
joe biden is in europe but he has no
idea he's in europe and the chinese and
russians are about to eat biden's launch
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben it's all the actual news in just a
moment but first i rarely do this but
today
i have a really important confession to
make
i've rethought my entire perspective on
equality
femininity female empowerment see i used
to believe that women deserved respect
because of all the incredible things
they do and accomplish
i looked to my wife as a model for a
woman who deserves respect a wife
a mother of three doctor community
member
a wonderful person but i have rethought
all of that
because of a new megan v stallion video
brilliantly titled thought
i was made aware of this video because
some of my viewers notified me the
reviewers of the video had said that
the song thought was directed at me
to which i responded what does thought
mean and also isn't megan the stallion
the woman who for some reason has a
middle name that means you
when it should actually just specify the
definite article but then i watched
her stunning music video and whole
vistas of philosophy were made available
to me new revelations with regard to
human excellence
were divulged the light shone forth i
was converted
to megan v stallion's brilliant world
view
as balum's ass made to him known the
wishes of the divine
so too did megan the stallion's ass make
known to all of us
the platonic meaning of true womanhood
for truly
civilization has rarely been graced with
a poet of such magnificence a gene
a genius of such magnitude an icon
of such genius i could go on and i will
but first
i wish to share her revelation and it is
a revelation
with us all for megan the stallion yes
my friends the stallion
is not the mere definite article but
within you
comes to share a message and we can do
little but gape in awe at her
astonishing
inspiring intellect insight sagacity
ah ye gods that we should have twerking
among us
such a paradigm of sheer perspective
sophistication
and enlightenment grateful we all should
be to live
in such a glorious time now to our
extraordinary
incandescent resplendent music video
[Applause]
hello look the women that
you accidentally trying to step on
are everybody that you depend on they
treat your diseases they cook your meals
they haul your trash drop your
ambulances they guard you while you
sleep
every part of your life do not
buy odin's beard the heartbreaking
wisdom
on my knees shaking ass on my thigh post
me a pig finna make me a profit
[Music]
anvil the aristotelian inside
by thor's great hammer the extraordinary
non-objectification and empowerment
the originality the virtuosity the
percipience
the praise it is all too little we must
investigate the supreme quality of megan
v
stallion's groundbreaking work within e
the true shakespearean artistic fluidity
rhyming
thought with both profit and toxic
but also rhyming venom with dinner
and also somehow finding the room to use
the word
12 times 44 times 24 times
five times and the n word seven times
all
in just under three minutes and in this
song
we learn that megan the stallion will
soon at the
shockingly prodigious age of just 26
graduate
from the prestigious texas southern
university with a degree in health
administration as she says
2021 finney graduate college
the true empowerment of this song hands
on my knees shaking
on my thought post me a pic final make
me
a prophet yes true female empowerment
is to be found in profiting from your
thought
the true beauty which lies within
exposed in the song
i walk around the house but naked and i
stop at every mirror just to stare at my
own posterior
yes meaning is to be found in gazing
narcissist-like
into the gaping maw of your own the true
honor and love
we ain't even speaking if the n-word
ain't spending
yes indeed true love and honor can only
be found in having sex with men
based purely on the amount of lucr they
spend on you yes
a thousand times yes hands on my knees
shaking
on my thought indeed
indeed after seeing
this unbelievably brilliant music video
i actually respect
my own wife less today because she
decided
to be an actual doctor and went to
college
and medical school and residency rather
than going to party city buying a hot
doctor outfit and then twerking for the
pleasure
of millions of men while reserving her
sexual favors only for those who pay her
the most money
my wife she just did not understand the
true uniqueness of womanhood
instead opted to get married bear
children care for those children
hold a job rather than dressing up in a
public sanitation worker outfit and
running over fake conservative senators
in a garbage truck
truly megan v stallion has set forth
an awe-inspiring vision of femininity
and womanhood
may we all remember her contribution to
humanity
as we forge forth to ever greater
civilizational heights
alrighty we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first
let us talk about the fact that my kids
keep me up all night and then i wake up
in the morning and i have to do shows
like this one
and that means i need my coffee but
there is one coffee that i
hold by i'm talking to you of course
about black rifle coffee black rifle
coffee is here to help fuel you along
your way this summer
black rifle coffee company it's a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee to people who love
america
veterans ceo and founder evan hafer
spent over seven years on the ground
overseas with u.s special forces
and as a cia contractor black rifle is
continually committed to supporting
veteran
law enforcement and first responder
causes and this summer black rifle
invites you to enjoy
your coffee by that they don't just mean
the great taste of america's coffee but
it's more about the places you drink it
the passion and adventure it fuels and
inspires the entertainment black rifle
serves
along the way because black rifle is
here to fuel you
they import high-quality coffee beans
from all over the world they roast five
days a week at their facilities in
manchester tennessee and salt lake city
utah
the team at black rifle is continually
researching and experimenting with new
roasting methods and coffee origins let
me tell you
i rely on black rifle coffee every
single morning fuel your summer with
america's coffee black rifle
coffee go to blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro to get 20
off your purchase and your first coffee
club order that is black
riflecoffee.com shapiro it is coffee
that will wake you up but will not make
you walk
go check them out right now
blackriflecoffee.com
shapiro alrighty so in actual news
joe biden has been abroad the big
problem is joe biden doesn't actually
know he's abroad
essentially joe biden's tenure thus far
is a lot like the anthony hopkins movie
the father
he's just wandering around not knowing
where he is and confused
all the time it's essentially an outtake
from the super bowl of the weekend
wandering through mirror-lined hallways
weirdly bumping into things
that is joe biden abroad and we were
told of course that donald trump had
shamed america on the world stage and
now america is
back baby america's back in fact anthony
blinken the
secretary of state he says the
foreigners love us again
the europeans they love us they love us
some yeah you know what the europeans
love they love when you give them what
they want
because politics is a power game and the
reality is the europeans know that joe
biden
thinks more like they do here is anthony
blinken
there was a major poll that just came
out that showed that across those
countries
75 percent of the people on average
now have confidence in american
leadership uh and in president biden
that's up from 17
a year ago so we're now in a position
where when it comes to dealing with
russia and the challenges it poses
or dealing with china and the challenges
it poses we can
uh come with a much more uh united front
oh is that what's going to happen in the
united front or maybe
it's that the europeans are comfortable
that we have a daughtering old fool in
the white house who is never going to
challenge any of their preconceived
notions about either russia or iran
about the middle east
they're just going to do whatever the
europeans would like them to do and why
exactly would they feel threatened by
joe biden
i mean this is this is the key to joe
biden he is perfectly unthreatening
because again
near corpses are not threatening this is
why the right
is not really glomming onto attacking
biden because how do you attack
a house plant as i've said many times
before so joe biden over and over
on this trip he demonstrated that he is
in fact barely sentient i mean it's
it's embarrassing there are folks in
america who said that donald trump was
an embarrassment on the world stage
because he was so brusque and because he
said crazy things are
fine it is embarrassing to have a
president of the united states
who is wandering into walls okay that is
we we've gotten to a certain point in
american life when these are the people
that we choose to be presidents
of the united states okay so joe biden
led off
the g7 by mixing up libya with syria
three times he was trying to talk about
how he was standing up
to the russians and also we were going
to work with the russians to end the
bloodshed in syria
but he missed by 1400 miles libya is
nowhere near syria in fact
it's not technically even on the same
land mass syria
is up there in that middle eastern land
mass and libya is down there in africa
here is joe biden
missing the mark by oh about 1400 miles
three times
in libya we should be opening up the the
the passes to be able to go through and
provide
provide um food assistance and economic
ass i mean
and for example the rebuilding of uh
of syria of uh of libya of
you know this is they're there so i'm
hopeful
that we can find an accommodation
that where we can save the lives of
people in for example
in uh in libya okay so um
here's the thing that's the wrong place
they're digging in the wrong place so
joe biden doesn't know where he is and
he doesn't know where syria is
also he gets very angry when you ask him
simple questions
so joe biden was asked about
what he is going to do to stand up to
the russians and the chinese and
and joe biden was like growling at the
reporters he's like i need more time i
mean first of all i don't know what
happened to his voice here
suddenly he became one of the demons
from poltergeist this is real weird
stuff
you've kept in place some trump-era
steel and aluminum sanctions
and i wanted to ask you when you're
having these conversations
with european allies who are very
concerned about these sanctions
how do you justify that and what are
your plans 120 days
give me a break need time
120 days give me a break
need time dude
what is going on what is happening right
now
okay and it was consistent it was like
across the entire g7
so first of all the g7 is always weird
right you always get these weird
pictures of these world leaders
awkwardly associating with one another
this time they opened their picture uh
their opening picture was of the g7
leaders in cornwall like on a beach in
cornwall
and they look like they just beamed down
except that angela merkel was wearing a
red jacket so she's the one who goes
first right is usually the way that this
works
but joe biden just he he's not with
us okay in the middle of one of his
press conferences he starts talking
again
about how he's gonna get in trouble with
his own staff if he answers unapproved
questions he does this all the time by
the way
he's saying the quiet part out loud he's
actually reading the stage direction
from the teleprompter
so here is joe biden doing that again
uh i'm sorry i'm gonna get in trouble
with staff i don't do this the right way
jennifer jacob bloomberg
i have to i have to i'll only answer
questions from the people my staff
tells me to answer broccoli
and then he um he tried to introduce the
presidents of south africa after boris
johnson already had
leading the entire g7 to laugh at him
things are going swimmingly
and and the president uh
so boris johnson reminds joe biden the
president of the united states that he
already introduced the person that joe
biden just tried to introduce
everybody starts laughing at joe biden
and joe biden awkwardly starts laughing
along
yes all is well on the international
stage um joe biden got lost in the wrong
cafe and had to be ushered away by a
young
female aide apparently uh this this was
put out by itv news so he's just walking
around the g7
he's supposed to be in a particular
place where is his staff
what are they doing he just wanders into
a cafe and everybody's looking at him
like what is going on why is the
president of the united states wandering
around in this cafe
asking for toilet paper or something
here is the president of your united
states
wandering around in a cafe before being
led away like a small child by an
aide how are your meetings going in
cornwall mr president
how are your meetings going here in
cornwall
they all are laughing at him there comes
his aide she's like
she's like come on joe come on come on
unbelievable unbelievable
and then there were his i mean his aides
have a rough job i mean it's a tough job
i understand i have children of my own
his aides we're trying to shoe away the
press there's a biden mccrone photo up
and his aides are like we need the
cameras to go away because
we need to get joe needs a nap joe needs
a rest just a little fussy gotta get him
his bottle
here here are his aides trying to shoot
away the press
all the press for shouting out questions
and his aides are like get out of here
go leave now is not the time
joe needs to lie down my god
yes yes things are great by the way you
wanna know the reason that the europeans
are very pro joe biden because he is
giving them all the things that he that
they want
including taxes on american corporations
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are working from home if you're working
at the office you don't want to go to
the post office okay waiting in line is
just not something that is worth doing
the post office is great they do a lot
of wonderful things but you can do all
the stuff that you could do at the post
office from your home or office and you
could do it for a lot less money and
save yourself time in the process
this is where stamps.com comes in thanks
to stamps.com you don't have to go to
the post office anymore you can mail and
ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters ship packages pay less
a lot less with discounted rates from
usps
ups and more stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours
tons of money every year here at
dailywire we've been using stamps.com
since 2017 no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings all the services of
the us postal service and ups
right to your computer it's a must-have
for any business whether you're a small
office sending invoices
a side hustle etsy shop shipping out
orders or just navigating the
hybridworklifebalancestamps.com can do
all of it
you can use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 any letter any
package any class email anywhere you
want to send it and
you get discounts up to 40 off post
office rates up to 66
off ups shipping rates and again
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
the expensive postage meters so don't go
to the post office anymore go to
stamps.com instead
no risk with my promo code shapiro you
get a special offer it includes a
four-week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
type in shapiro that is stamps.com promo
code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again
alrighty so the
g7 what happened there a few things well
one the united states basically asked
other countries to tax american-based
corporations now
you don't have to love the big tech
companies to understand that these are
america-based corporations
and the fact they're based in america
means a lot of the jobs exist here in
the united states
and that we take for whatever taxes they
pay we take
the chief margin of those taxes because
they are based
in the united states okay well now the
united states government
under the auspices of joe biden and
janet yellen wishes to announce a global
tax on tech companies
the goal is to tax american tech giants
according to the wall street journal
editorial board
new rules would allow jurisdictions
where global companies earn revenue
market countries to tax a portion of the
resulting profits this would upend a
century of global standards that tax
companies where their headquarters are
based the g7 makes it sound like this
would apply to all large global firms
one might even think it's an improvement
on the patchwork of digital services
taxes the g7 promises to replace
but janet yellen and her peers didn't
devise this idea in a vacuum
their proposal builds on negotiations
already underway at the organization for
economic cooperation and development
the oecd for taxes that would apply
specifically to digital companies
so in other words you might think that
their new rule which taxes profits where
they are earned would be good for the
united states or a giant market that
means that a bunch of businesses selling
their products over here would get to
tax that
except for the fact that this is
explicitly designed in order to tax only
giant companies based in the united
states
the exemption of profits up to a margin
of 10 is the clue in only a few
industries do companies consistently
achieve profit margins above that
threshold digital services is one such
industry
negotiators are carving out exclusions
for other industries that otherwise
would have to pay the tax
a few non-tech companies may eventually
get caught but witness the efforts to
minimize their numbers
one step is ms yellen's offer this
spring to limit the new tax to companies
with revenue above 20 billion dollars
which captures most american tech firms
and excludes the vast majority of the
world's other multinational companies so
basically we're going to allow everybody
to tax america-based companies
but we are not going to be able to tax
their companies in return
amazing work i can't imagine why the g7
loves joe biden so much why
why i mean clearly joe biden is a leader
and meanwhile according to the new york
times there are cracks in the coalition
president biden and fellow western
leaders issued a confrontational
declaration about russian and chinese
government behavior on sunday
castigating beijing over its
international over over its internal
repression
vowing to investigate the pandemic's
origins and excoriating moscow for using
nerve agents in cyber
and cyber weapons concluding the first
in-person summit meeting
since the outbreak of the coveted
pandemic the leaders tried to present a
unified front against a range of threats
but
they disagreed about crucial issues from
from timelines for halting the burning
of coal to committing tens or hundreds
of billions of dollars to aid
to challenge beijing's belt and road
initiative still as they left cornwall
where they had met at a resort
overlooking rocky outcroppings in
england's far west almost all of the
participants welcomed a new tone
as they began to repair the breaches
from four years of dealing with biden's
predecessor
donald j trump president emmanuel macron
of france said
it's great to have a u.s president who's
part of the club and very willing to
cooperate yes i've noticed
i've noticed yeah so so basically
the united states is going to get
nothing out of this instead what's going
to happen is that the united states
is going to cave to everything that
europe wants which means that the united
states will look the other way
and actually actively promulgate iranian
involvement in the world economy
the united states will green light
things like the nordstrom 2 pipeline
while killing keystone xl
the united states will look the other
way as the as china rolls over countries
in the surrounding
regions the fact of the matter is this
administration has zero interest
in facing up to russia or china this
administration has demonstrated very
little willingness
to actually take harsh action with
regard to either the putin regime or the
xi jinping regime
over in china it's pretty obvious that
they wish to do exactly what the
europeans want to do which is dither
around
until these regimes continue to gain
strength which is kind of amazing
because we were told for years that it
was
donald trump who was a cat's paw of
russians
and then donald trump you know he was
just he was racist against the chinese
that was the big problem he just kept
being racist when he said things like
wuhan
virus now in reality when u.s leadership
is soft the europeans
like to the europeans are all for soft
us leadership until we have to come in
and save their asses every 40 years but
the reality is that a soft united states
means a more powerful china more
powerful russia
actors on the world stage getting
aggressive and that's about that's what
we're about to see we'll get to that in
just one moment first
let us talk about your workout routine
so let me tell you
i've been using my echelon machine
pretty much every day and it is just
great echelon is the affordable way to
get workout equipment
the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right
in the comfort of your own home in fact
echelon is so good i got one for my
parents i got one
for my brother-in-law as well echelon's
fitness app provides you with thousands
of live and on-demand classes with great
music
from your favorite artist with echelon
you can work out any time day or night
and crush
your fitness goals you just pick your
class climb the leaderboard cheer each
other on give it your all you can track
your workouts and progress to reach
your fitness goals the machine itself
it's it's great
it's comfortable it's easy to use it
doesn't take up a lot of space
and again it's going to help you keep
fit take off the weight do what it is
you're looking to do to get fit echelon
certified fitness instructors are
supportive
engaging and fun and they know how to
get you moving they've got a full range
of affordable workout equipment they've
got the stationary bikes of course they
also have smart rollers they have
fitness screens they have auto folding
treadmills
all connected with that echelon
experience you get the feeling like get
a personal trainer in your house with
you and right now my listeners will get
a special offer from echelon for a
limited time only start your 30-day risk
free trial offer with echelon's ex3 bike
for just one
dollar it's a special risk-free offer
for 30 days with echelon's ex3 bike for
only one
dollar to start plus free shipping the
only way to get that special offer go to
n f i echelonfit.com dot com slash ben
echelon fit.com can't speak of it highly
enough it really is terrific okay
so when it comes to foreign policy this
administration
has essentially no interest in doing
anything about china so the g7
put out a statement about how we need to
hold china accountable here's what their
statement said quote strengthening
transparency and accountability
including reiterating our commitment to
the full implementation of
and improved compliance with the
international health regulations of
2005.
this includes investigating reporting
and responding to outbreaks of unknown
origin
we also call for a timely transparent
expert-led and science-based
who convened phase 2 covenant 19 origin
study including as recommended by the
experts report
in china so the g7 is like we're going
to hold china accountable
by going to the world health
organization the chinese run
organization
that covered four china's malfeasance in
the early months of the pandemic that
lied to the world that china's behest in
late january and said that covet 19
was not human to human transmission
right the who is a chinese tool
and now you got the entire g7 being like
you know what let's let the who do its
work i mean it's got to be the who here
right
joe biden called for transparency from
china
i mean or he was eating oatmeal with a
fork one of the two here he was
i think china has to start to act
uh more responsibly in terms of
international norms on human rights
and transparency transparency matters
across the board we have to build a
system
whereby we can know what when
we see another transparent
uh lack of transparency would might
produce another
vax a a a another pandemic we have to
have access
um yes he is definitely going to be able
to stand up to this chinese
authoritarian regime when he cannot make
it through a sentence
and also has sort of a congenital
unwillingness to face up to the threat
that china
represents i love that senior biden
officials according to politico have
said investigations in the into the
pandemic's origins
should be shepherded by an independent
international body like the who
but the wh first crack at the
investigation released in march
called the lab leak quote extremely
unlikely after an investigation
here's the parenthetically ready however
china did not share key lab data and
records
oh so you mean they came up with a
finding that's completely not grounded
in any sort of data because the chinese
wouldn't provide the data
to the all-knowing all-seeing who
secretary of state anthony blinken was
asked about this so you guys keep saying
you want to hold china accountable and
you want to get to the bottom of this
and then you're kicking it over to the
whole so um you got any idea like how
you're going to pressure china to be
involved in investigating itself here
here's anthony blinken
inspiring stuff from the secretary of
state
we need to get to the bottom of what
happened uh we need accountability
but we also need to understand what
happened why it happened how it happened
if we're going to be able to put in
place uh the necessary measures to
prevent it from happening again or at
least to be in a better place to
mitigate the next pandemic if we can't
fully prevent one
and so we need we need this transparency
we need this information
uh the who you're right uh the first
study that they put out
was highly deficient the leaders of the
g7 have come together insisting that
china cooperate with the so-called phase
two study by the who
to really get to the bottom of what
happened oh so
that very very encouraging now i'm i
feel
secure in their hands things are going
to go absolutely spectacularly while
here
okay so i'm so glad they've called for a
probe of china
everything's gonna be great just great
meanwhile how's going on on russia
so joe biden is supposed to meet with
vladimir putin
okay and um he knows he's about to get
his lunch eaten publicly by putin
because putin is still very much with it
putin is out there wrestling bears and
icy rivers and crap
also he's a murderer okay so first of
all
you have to admire vladimir putin's
commitment to being a bond supervillain
have you ever seen his house in sochi
you're gonna have to get a picture of
his house in sochi it looks like a bond
super lair a
super villain super layer it's pretty
spectacular and of course he murders
enemies
and or jails them so vladimir putin was
asked this straight up
by a reporter from nbc news so um are
you a killer
and poon's like mr bond it's
pretty his commitment to the role is
pretty spectacular
mr president are you a kid
over my tenure i've gotten used to
attacks from all kinds of angles
and from all kinds of areas under all
kinds of pretext and reasons
and of different caliber and fierceness
and none of it surprises me
so as far as harsh rhetoric i think that
this is an expression of overall u.s
culture
of course in hollywood there are some
underlying deep things in hollywood
macho which can be treated as cinematic
art
but that's part of u.s political culture
where it's considered normal
okay and then you cut to the postscript
where that reporter is dead in his room
and vladimir putin's hand's been
poisoned with uranium or something
in any case joe biden is supposed to
face up to vladimir putin
now there's a lot of talk about how
donald trump was enthralled to the
russians right he was a russian
tool they had twisted the election in
favor of of
donald trump there's only one problem
which is the donald trump was a lot
harsher on the russians than barack
obama was barack obama handed syria over
to the russians handed part of ukraine
over to the russians with pretty much
no repercussions at all okay so joe
biden was asked about
you know are you going to do like a
joint pressure with vladimir putin how's
any that's going to work
and give credit to biden at least he's
sentient enough to know that he's not
sentient he's like i'm not going to do a
press with vladimir putin because if i
do a
pressure with vladimir putin he's going
to look alive and i'm barely alive
this is not a contest about who can do
better in front of a press conference or
try to embarrass
each other it's about making myself very
clear
what the conditions are to get a better
relationship
are with russia we're not looking for
conflict we are looking to resolve
those actions which we think are
inconsistent with international norms
we're not looking for conflict we're
looking to be friends yes this is going
to go extremely low meanwhile nancy
pelosi
another geriatric daughter explains that
uh vladimir putin is going to meet his
match
in joe biden yes yes i'm sure i mean
i'm sure that putin isn't just going to
deceive him and lie to him and be
exactly the sort of evil dictator he's
been for you know 20
years at this point he's probably
probably this guy
joe biden this house plant over here is
going to stand up to vladimir putin
in magnificent ways again i'm rooting
for the president of the united states
to do better here i'm rooting for him to
stand up to china and rooting for him to
stand up to russia he is not
congenitally disposed to do this
nor is he i think mentally capable of
standing up to vladimir putin
at this point by all available
indicators but here's nancy pelosi
showing us probably we should take her
at her word
the president of former president of the
united states
for whatever reason whether the russians
had personal political or financial
uh leverage over him just ca
towed catered to putin in a way that was
humiliating to the united states of
america
and when when putin hears about
some of the violations of of the rights
of his own people he laughs
this is a thug this is a thug but he is
the
head of an important state in terms of
the issues you raised
the president should meet with him uh
and i i
i think he's going to meet a very
different president than one
who was at the mercy of putin hmm
so yes i'm sure yes i i nancy pelosi is
the kind of person who definitely would
stand up to bad actors right i mean
she's assuring us here that joe biden
will stand up to bad actors and donald
trump was weak
but nancy pelosi herself is the kind of
person who would stand up to bad actors
right
yeah not so much we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about the greatest father's
day gift you can give
i'm talking about meat i'm talking about
steak
i'm talking of course about omaha steaks
omaha steaks delivers guaranteed quality
and safety with every order every order
is flash frozen vacuum sealed safely
delivered in a cooler with dry ice stays
ready to cook
in the freezer for months omaha steaks
has an amazing limited time father's day
offer just released
for my listeners go to omahasteaks.com
enter the code shapiro into the search
bar order
the dad's best grill pack for 99.99
here's what you got
28 of omaha steaks his favorite entrees
i mean
for like 100 bucks four bacon wrap
fillets four premium boneless chicken
breasts four boneless pork chops eight
gourmet jumbo franks plus the all-time
favorite made from scratch
caramel apple tartlets omaha steaks
signature seasoning packet and
eight free filet mignon burgers for just
99.99
i mean that is a hell of a deal and let
me tell you they gave me a kosher omaha
steak years ago i still
dream about this i mean look at that
deal that's an amazing deal it's an
unbelievable offer at 59
savings the packages are selling out
fast do not wait go to omahastakes.com
use the keyword shapiro order the dad's
best grill pack today
that is omahasteaks.com keyword shapiro
for a 59
savings and eight free filet mignon
burgers go check them out
right now man that is a great deal
father's day gift from omaha steaks
alrighty we'll get to more
in the news in just one second first if
you have seen the walk away series on
youtube you've likely stumbled on the
video of our very own georgia hell a
former teacher and liberal who saw the
ideological indoctrination sweeping the
nation she was brave enough to publicly
stand against it
in her new show office hours she offers
her unique perspective as a former
leftist which you can now get anywhere
you go with the office hours podcast go
check it out whether it's discussing
critical race theory with co-author of
the ground breaking grievance
studies james lindsay or transgenderism
with the author of irreversible damage
abigail schreier
her show offers a wealth of incredible
information from some of america's most
important voices
you can download you can listen to it
anywhere so subscribe and download
office hours with georgia howe
on apple podcast or whatever your
platform of choice may be get ready for
the ultimate listening experience no
matter where you are
also if you like listening to me debunk
leftist lies you'll love hearing candace
owens do the same thing and if you want
to be able to do that no matter where
you go you should download and subscribe
candace the audio podcast whether she's
asking donald trump
questions like whether she can hop on
his ticket in 2024 or giving feminism
the roast it always deserves
her panel of guests you're always
guaranteed a smart funny
interesting listening experience again
download and subscribe to candace the
audio podcast on apple spotify or
wherever you get your podcast be sure to
leave a five star review keep her
podcast trending in the charts
the way her name trends on twitter
you're listening to the fastest growing
largest conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so meanwhile nancy pelosi is explaining
that joe biden is going to stand up to
vladimir putin
a couple of things one joe biden is not
in fact standing up to vladimir putin in
fact how much is he not doing so well
president biden apparently said over the
weekend that he would be doing swaps of
cyber criminals with moscow
and he said well if moscow catches
american cyber criminals and we catch
russian cyber criminals maybe we'll just
swap them you know like we'll just swap
them out um and then the white house is
like not you know what we're not going
to do that
the white house like pay no attention to
grandpa over there because he doesn't
know what in the world he is talking
about biden had entertained an idea
putin floated in a tv interview
about x-rating criminals who engaged in
ransom hacking either against the united
states or russia when he was asked about
it at a press conference
biden was like you know maybe maybe we
could talk about swapping criminals
and then um and then the white house is
like yeah don't pay attention to him
because uh he's crazy
so that's going well meanwhile nancy
pelosi saying that joe biden is
definitely going to stand up to vladimir
putin
nancy pelosi cannot stand up to a to a
mild wind i mean we know that joe biden
can't either like he falls down air
force one stairs if there's
a breeze that's above seven miles an
hour apparently but nancy pelosi cannot
stand up to her own party in the
slightest you'll remember the last week
there's a large-scale conflagration when
12 house democrats condemned ilhan omar
and asked her to clarify
her anti-semitic and anti-american
comments and then
she sort of walked them back a little
bit and then nancy pelosi i guess we're
done here
so over the weekend she was asked about
this and she was asked
you know have you chided ilhan omar at
all and nancy pelosi
was like everything's fine with hill
hunt she's she's great she's
here we go nancy pelosi you know the
person who is saying we need to stand up
to vladimir putin she can't even stand
up
to the anti-american wing of her own
party
congresswoman omar is a valued member of
our caucus she
asked her questions of the secretary of
state nobody criticized those about
how people will be held accountable if
we're not going to the international
court of justice that was a very
legitimate question
that was not of concern members did
become concerned
when the tweet that was put out equated
the united states
with taliban and hamas
and policing and and
then she clarified it and we thanked her
for clarification so do you want
people to just let it go they could say
whatever they want but what i'm saying
is
is end of subject she clarified
we thanked her end of subject oh well um
she clarified we thanked her end of
subject yeah except for
you know that that little calendar from
futurama that says days since illinois
said something terribly
anti-american and or anti-semitic and
now it's reading like two
it's been like two days yeah that that
calendar has never gotten to more than
about 20.
okay so we'll just be right back here in
a couple of weeks and nancy pelosi will
surrender to the squad
once again meanwhile the squad continues
to fuel its oats
alexandra ocasio-cortez out there in
public ripping this democratic
leadership so meanwhile
while the democratic leadership is like
ilhan is doing great we love her she's
leave her on the foreign affairs
committee here is alexander
ocasio-cortez
uh a full-scale dullard slamming the
democratic leadership for rebuking
ilhanimar how dare they
like like it's just oh like like wow
we know that uh you know these very
intense news cycles which by the way
started this whole hubbub started with
right-wing
uh news outlets taking what she said out
of context and when we feed into that it
adds legitimacy to
a lot of this kind of right-wing vitriol
it absolutely
kind of increases um
that that target and as someone who has
experienced that
uh you know it's it's very difficult to
communicate
um the scale and
how dangerous you know that so that's
dangerous oh it is oh it's so dangerous
it's her life is so tough alexandra
weeper
it's just it's unbelievable right so i
mean nancy pelosi is cowtailing with
these folks
and meanwhile they got aoc out there
like you know it started with the right
really were all those jewish democrats
right-wingers i missed it they're all
registered democrats
in the democratic party elected
democrats who are ripping on
ilhan omar and yet it so there she is
how could
and nancy pelosi clearly is a
right-winger secretly she's a
right-winger according to aoc
meanwhile alexander ocasio-cortez didn't
merely limit herself to attacking the
democratic leadership in the house
she was also attacking the senate
democrats because it turns out that the
smartest way to ensure that your radical
legislation gets passed
is by crapping all over joe manchin and
kristen cinema that's definitely going
to work here is
alexandra ocasio-cortez using her
her strategic mind i mean she's she's so
strategic guys i mean she's brilliant at
this
she's she's von klauswitz like here she
is
i do think that we need to talk about
the elephant in the room
which is senate democrats which are
blocking crucial items in a democratic
agenda
um for very i think
uh for reasons that i don't think hold a
lot of water
and for folks saying okay you know we
need where are you going to get these 50
votes
i think we really need to start asking
some of these democratic senators
where they plan on getting 60 votes um
so
yeah so she's attacking the house
democratic leadership and the senate
democratic leadership
here's the thing about the democratic
party and their majority right now it is
a fragile coalition
it's a coalition of people like joe
manchin who has nothing in common with
aoc
and kristen cinema who has very little
in common with aoc and then
aoc and the house democrats have decided
that they need to cater to the most woke
among them the most progressive members
of their own party which is silliness
those are the people you need to cater
to the least seriously they're going to
vote with your progressive priorities
when you actually encode those in
legislation
when's the last time that these votes
were the swing voters
really if you want your party to be able
to pass anything you need to be looking
to to placate the blue dogs
you don't need to be looking to placate
your far left wing but nancy pelosi is
so scared crapless
of the squad that she continues to just
feed them more rope
they're gonna hang her with it i mean
it's amazing it's amazing to watch
meanwhile aoc also had words about
whether justice breyer
should retire yeah i'm sure that justice
breyer is sitting there just
on tensor hooks waiting to hear what aoc
has to say about whether he should leave
his uh leave his position
on the supreme court just to be clear
you do think that
justice stephen breyer should retire at
the end of this term
um you know i i i it's something i think
about but i
i would probably lean towards yes
um but yes you're actually you're asking
me this question so i just i would give
more thought to it but
uh but i'm inclined to say yes yes and
i'm sure that justice breyer will take
that under advisement
uh also aoc said the quiet part out loud
she said that we have to rig
the election processes from now and we
can't just rely on winning elections
anymore she says
especially if senate democrats are not
going to pass
reforms on hr1 we cannot
rely solely on on
a wish of winning elections
particularly in the senate when voting
rights are under attack in georgia
arizona and texas across
the country and if we're not going to
pass hr one with the preemptive clauses
that can roll some of that uh voter
suppression attacks back
yeah i believe that we should protect
our supreme court and i thought that
should absolutely be a consideration um
yeah i mean we can't rely on winning
elections anymore it's probably better
if we if we just rely on
rigging the strate the strategy by which
we vote in the first place
meanwhile democratic governance in the
city continues to be absolutely terrible
statistics out of atlanta
demonstrate massive increases in
homicides
according to the atlanta journal
constitution after historically deadly
2020 atlanta homicides are up nearly 60
in 2021 it turns out radicalism has
consequences
according to the atlanta journal
constitution
atlanta police have investigated 64
homicide cases in 2021
a 58 increase over this time last year
the surge follows a historically deadly
when authorities investigated 157
homicide cases the most in more than two
decades
mayor kisha lance bottoms has referred
to the spike in violence as a covid
crime wave
but the city's death toll continues to
mount as more georgians get vaccinated
and life returns to normal
because it wasn't a coveted crime wave
gang it was a blm crime wave
okay we all know when the crime wave
began and it wasn't with the beginning
of kovat
as of june atlanta's murders are up and
shootings have increased by 40
according to the latest data meanwhile
overall arrests are down by about 43
percent
as atlanta's police force remains more
than 400 officers
under its authorized level more than 200
officers quit the force in 2020
many after criminal charges were filed
against the two officers involved in the
deadly shooting of rayshard brooks and
other officers who used their tasers on
two college students during last
summer's protest downtown
another 75 atlanta police officers have
left since the start of the year records
show
but department leaders say that morale
is stabilizing they plan to hire 250 new
officers in the next fiscal year
beginning july 1st except for how that's
not going to work at all because it
turns out that when you take up
radical grievances and destroy the law
enforcement community
it's very difficult to restaff dr karen
sullivan fulton county medical
examiner said her office conducts death
examinations from cities across fulton
most of the homicide victims they
encounter are killed in atlanta remember
mayor keisha lance adams was widely
considered a final possibility for joe
biden as his vp candidate
and she's presided over this mass murder
increase in her city
anecdotally it seems as though the
complexity of the homicides is
increasing said sullivan
years ago the vast majority of homicide
cases due to gunshot wounds were one
maybe two rarely rarely three gunshot
wounds now it's quite common for people
to have been shot 10 or 12 times
so things are going great in atlanta
crime atlanta has become a central issue
in this year's race for city hall
especially after bottoms announced she
would not seek re-election
in the fall some have called for
buckhead residents to break away and
form their own city
state officials have started stepping in
to address atlanta's rising crime
homicides are up in many cities across
the nation yet critics believe atlanta
has not done all it could
to stem the rise in violent crime many
saw bottoms as slow to respond to the
surge in killings momentum was building
for opposition in november's election
even before
she dropped out of the race and this is
happening in major cities
across the country because the radicals
are in
control and now the democrats wish to
extend that radicalism
across the spectrum make no mistake the
doj policy pursued by the biden
administration which is directed against
police departments across the nation
will result in fewer officers working
will result in less policing by the
officers who do work
it will result in more crime
it's amazing how good intentions are for
the left invariably paired with crappy
results
meanwhile you have the entire democratic
party circulating around the idea now
they've come up the economy is falling
apart right we can see that the economy
is in serious trouble
right now because we have something like
9 million open jobs and
3.5 million people applying for those
jobs only gained 3.5 million jobs
since this pandemic effectively ended
and that is because of the bad economic
policy pushed by the biden
administration
and yet every day we hear how they're
going to double down every day and in
fact now they're beginning to change
their messaging they've got ezra klein
over at the new york times he put out a
piece today
literally talking about how it's good
that we are paying people to stay out of
the job market
it's good now they're always going to
move the goal post the goal post used to
be look how many jobs we're creating
now it's look how many jobs we're not
creating because you know if we pay
people to stay out of the workforce then
maybe we'll raise wages as a result
good luck with all of this democrats you
break it you bought it and you don't
have trump to kick around anymore so at
a certain point you're gonna have to
start to govern
good luck to you alrighty we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael muller show today
he discusses youtube censoring is
sitting at united states center you can
hear more details about that story over
on michael's show that is available
right this moment
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
joe biden becomes a laughing stock at
the g7 summit
blm race hustlers turn on each other and
youtube censors a sitting u.s senator
check it out on the michael knoll show
you